but then you have something like Bitcoin
I believe Regulators said they can't
regulate Bitcoin how do you regulate a
decentralized asset which is also
Anonymous even in the EU they're trying
to regulate crypto they want to regulate
the nonky wallet so the exchanges are
easy to regulate either you abide by our
rules or we shut you down right but with
the apps and The Ledges and the
treasures and and all of that they want
people to screenshot their wallet with
their name and everything and it's funny
cuz it's like how do you implement that
that's a nice idea but like how do you
Poli that you just can't I think it's
going to be very interesting to see
governments try and shut it down